what is the perimeter of the figure
below so down here we have this figure
and we are asked to find the perimeter
of this figure perimeter is the distance
all the way around the outside of a
shape so in this case if I were to walk
around the outside or maybe a human's
too big if an awesome little ant was to
walk all the way around the outside of
this figure how far she walked would be
the perimeter so to find that what we
can do is figure out how long is this
side and then combine it with the length
of this side and combine it with the
length of this side and once we combine
all of the side links we'll have the
perimeter or the distance around the
outside of the figure so let's start we
can start up here we can see that this
side length is 5 centimeters so we have
5 centimeters plus moving down the side
here we have another 3 centimeters and
then going across next distance is 4
centimeters after that we go down this
side right here which is another 4
centimeters and as we keep going across
the bottom we have another 9 centimeters
and then we head up this side and uh-oh
we don't have a label we don't know how
far this is but to find perimeter we
need the distance around the entire
outside if this little ant she walked
the whole way we've got to know the
entire distance she walked so what we
can do is we can look over here and say
this length right here is 3 centimeters
well then that same length over here is
also 3 centimeters and where that 3
centimeters left off this 4 centimeters
this length picked up so from here to
here is another 4 centimeters
so if we have four centimeters plus
another three centimeters that's a total
of seven more centimeters so now we know
the entire all of the lengths around the
outside so if we combine them or add
them we'll know the perimeter so we can
start five plus three is eight four plus
four is another eight nine plus seven
let's see instead of seven I could do
nine plus one and six because that's the
same as seven nine plus one is ten and
ten plus six is sixteen eight plus eight
is another sixteen so we have a 16 and a
16 16 let's see six 1s plus six more
ones is 12 ones and one 10 plus another
10 or 10 plus 10 is 20 so another way we
could add this is 20 plus 12 which is a
total of 32 and we were talking about
centimeters here so 32 centimeters the
distance all the way around the outside
of this figure or the perimeter of the
figure is 32 centimeters